[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في موجز الاخبار اعلنت تجهيزه
الامن الاسرائيليه ان يوسف ابو جابر من
بلده كفر قاسم في جنوب منطقه المثلث داخل
الخط الاخضر هو منفذ عمليه الدهسه التي
وقعت في متنزه على شاطئ البحر في تل ابيب
وقد اسفرت في العمليه عن مقتل السائح
الايطالي واصابه خمسه اثنان منهم في حاله
خطيره وكلهم اجانب وقالت الشرطين منفذ
العمليه دهس عمدا مجموعه من المشاه قبل
انحراف سيارته وانقلابها كما اكدت الشرطه
ان احد افرادها هرع الى المكان فلاحظ ان
السائق حاول الترجل واشهر سلاحنا كان
بحوزته فعاجله واطلق عليه النار وقتله من
جهته قال الاسعاف الاسرائيلي ان القتيل
الايطالي قتل بالرصاص وليس بفعل عمليه
الدهس واكدت ان المنفذه لم يطلق اي رصاصه
وتاتي عمليه تل ابيب بعد ساعاتنا من هجوم
استهدف السياره في منطقه الحمراء شرق بلده
طوباس في الاغوار الشماليه وادى الى مقتل
مستوطنتين واصابه ثلاثه او ثالثه بجروح
خطيره
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو
بتعبئه كل وحدات الاحتياط في حرس الحدود
وتحريك قوات اضافيه لمواجهه ما وصفها
بموجه الارهاب المتصاعده كما قال نتنياهو
انه يجب على السكان غلاف غزه ان يكونوا
مستعدين لايام صعبه قريبه
جاء تصريحات نتنياهو بعد قصف مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه واراضي زراعيه في
مناطق متفرقه من غزه فجر امس ردت عليه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بدفعات صاروخيه
استهدفت المستوطنات المتاخمه للقطاع
قالت حركه حماس والجهاد الاسلامي انهما
ابلغت كلا من مصر والوسط قطر والامم
المتحده بان الفصائل ستواصل اطلاق
الصواريخ اذا واصل الاحتلال العدوان
والغارات الجويه او الاعتداءات على
المصلين والمعتكفين في المسجد الاقصى
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان وسقط طائر مسير
عبرت من لبنان الى الاراضي الاسرائيليه
كما نقلت اذاعه الجيش عن مصادر امنيه
اسرائيليه ان المسير التي اسقطها الجيش
تابعه لحزب الله
من جهته وجه رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالتعبئه واستدعاء جنود الاحتياط مع
التركيز على الدفاع الجوي والطيران وقد
نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولين في وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه تفضيلهم تركيز الضربات
في غزه ولبنان على اهداف لحركه حماسه في
محاوله لتجنب صراع اوسع مع حزب الله
هذا واكده وزاره الخارجيه في لبنان عزمها
على تقديم شكوى الى مجلس الامن احتجاجا
على الاعتداء الاسرائيلي على جنوب البلاد
كما اكدت السلطات اللبنانيه التزامها
بالحفاظ على الهدوء
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه انها ارسلت الى
الشرق الاوسط غواصه نوويه مزوده بصواريخ
موجهه لدعم الامن في المنطقه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]